You might be sitting there thinking
that Colt is over doing it a bit.
After all, he does have
a tendency to come on strong.
And anyway, performance is important
in that way that dental cleanings are.
Everyone knows you should
think about getting them, but
nobody really wants too.
But as any grandmother would tell you,
you don't actually have to floss
all of your teeth just the ones
that you want to keep.
And similarly, you don't need
to think about performance for
all of your apps,
just the ones that you want to succeed.
Because Colt brought up a good point.
Users will complain about app
performance three times as often as any
other issues.
So keep in mind that just because
your app works beautifully in your
development environment with its perfect
Wi-Fi on your fancy new test phone
doesn't mean it will always work well.